et le etc qui se poursuivait donc cette
semaine voilà on pleure beaucoup à
l'entrée de l'école alors j'imagine que
parmi vous il ya beaucoup de jeunes
papas de jeunes mamans qui emmenait pour
la première fois leur fils ou leur fille
à l'école c'était dur pour pour lui ou
pour elle mais c'est aussi dur pour les
parents parce qu'on est bloqués de
l'autre côté de la classe et on les voit
partir en pleurant comme ça alors on ait
eu l'idée que l'argent pitié d'aller
voir comment ça se passe lorsqu'on vous
avez viré lorsque vous étiez plus à
l'école que tout était fermé que les
portes étaient claqué qu'on donne un
petit coup d'oeil par dessus la verrière
de qu'on voyait rien comment se passe
non seulement l'accueil mais comment
s'installe les enfants dans leur nouvel
univers dans cette salle de classe qui
sera leur univers pendant pendant neuf
mois et vous allez voir c'est à la fois
troublant mais quand même bien rassurant
malgré les apparences l'intégration à la
classe va se faire très vite
la maîtresse cherche à établir un
premier contact symbolique les moins
timides accepte l'engagement mais les
réticences sont nombreuses sans cri sans
larmes sept enfants s'est tout de suite
en fermé sur lui-même il faudra sans
doute plusieurs jours pour l'apprivoiser
l'attrait de la nouveauté commence à
faire son effet plus à l'aise les petits
curieux partent à la découverte de la
classe ils prennent possession des lieux
l'unité du groupe se forme spontanément
autour des pinceaux et des couleurs
chacun apporte sa contribution à
l'oeuvre collective la classe sous
d'elle-même sans l'aide de la maîtresse
c'est gribouillis sont à l'image de la
classe qui se cherchent et se trouve la
communication s'établit par gestes cris
bruit ou regard mais deux heures a fait
la rentrée aucune parole n'a été
échangée
on sent que les dernières défenses sont
sur le point de tomber pendant la
récréation les solitaires et les timides
gravitent autour de la maîtresse
ces échanges de coups sont aussi une
façon de se mesurer et de se connaître
après la récréation une nouvelle étape
est franchie on se parle
alors petits groupes le dialogue
s'instaure autour des futurs leaders de
la classe juste avant l'arrivée des
moments l'intimité du groupe et créer la
nouvelle classe est né voilà j'ai